mary trump has announced that she will
be pulling her podcast from spotify in
protest of joe rogan talking to
scientists that she doesn't like which
is pretty shocking news for all of us
mary trump has a podcast mary trump
the whiny niece of the former president
there are now so many podcasts
that even the whiny niece of the former
president who has never done a single
thing in her entire life other than be
the whiny niece of the former president
has one
it's too much it's too much there's too
much noise
this is the final straw i am calling for
a complete and total shutdown of all new
podcasts until we figure out what the
hell is going on i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday speaking of things i'm
calling for is from buckman who says
love the michael knowles pledge
hope more and more candidates from both
sides publicly sign it yes the pledge is
the michael knowles public health
protection pledge says two things if you
get elected to congress in 2022 you will
vote to subpoena dr fauci and you will
vote to zero out his budget
his salary rather get rid of his salary
make it so that he's not receiving a
paycheck those are the two things make
sure i need your help get your current
congressman get your senator
senators i guess
get them to sign this pledge get the
candidates who are asking for your vote
right now get them to sign this pledge i
want these people on the record a
republican who will not vote to get rid
of fouchy is completely useless they
don't deserve to be in congress they are
they are not in any appreciable way
conservative
get rid of them
get them to sign the pledge all right
you're gonna be getting a lot of emails
from candidates asking for your
support okay and one of the best ways to
send out emails to lots and lots of
people constant contact constant contact
is a digital marketing platform that
helps small businesses and non-profits
of all sizes build grow and succeed i
have used constant contact for over a
dozen years now it is just the o.g
reliable extremely sophisticated always
is going to work email marketing contact
management system it's just great i've
trusted it for over a decade they've got
industry leading list growth tools
social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all from one easy to use platform
they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing
with a 97 deliverability rate you can
rest assured that your customers and
potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time with
very simple interface even i could use
it constant contact's easy to use
platform makes contact management easier
than ever they've got powerful
automation tools it's just it's so
simple to use to start your free digital
marketing trial today visit constant
contact
mary trump is pulling her podcast
informing people for the first time that
mary trump has a podcast
i
hate to say i told you so
but i told you so i said the other day
while i was humming joni mitchell songs
i had neil young all weekend i had you
know old man trey go look at milo i said
why am i what do i have neil young in my
head oh right because he got himself in
the news by opposing joe rogan i said at
this point we just have
forgotten artists
and even not not only has-beens but
never never was's
are now just using this joe rogan
non-traversing to get their names out
there
and then mary trump proved it
now for the first time ever people have
heard of the mary trump podcast we are
in the pure
opportunism phase of the joe rogan
non-traversing and it's not just coming
from hippies from the 60s and it's not
just coming from political hacks trying
to cash in on their family name
it's coming from the white house gensake
from the white house press briefing room
pressured spotify
to censor joe rogan even more than they
already have
our hope is that all major tech
platforms and all major news sources for
that matter be responsible and be
vigilant to ensure the american people
have access to accurate information on
something as significant as covid19 that
certainly includes spotify so this
disclaimer it's a positive step but we
want every platform to continue doing
more to call out misinformation
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information i mean look at the
facts right you are 16 times more likely
to be hospitalized if you're
unvaccinated and 68 times more likely to
die than someone who is boosted if
you're unvaccinated that's pretty
significant and we think that is
something that unquestionably should be
the basis of how people are
communicating about it but ultimately uh
you know our view is it's a it's a good
step it's a positive step but there's
more that can be done the fact that
spotify will now put a disclaimer on
only those podcasts of joe rogan that i
don't like
only the podcasts that dissent from the
liberal orthodoxy that's a good step
the fact that spotify is now pressuring
joe rogan to have more democrats and
establishmentarians and libs on his show
that's a good step but we need more
i
never again want to hear the phrase
build your own platform
this is something that the squishes have
really relied on in recent years and the
libs as well both the libs and the
squishes they very often team up build
your own sure of course we need to build
our own platform we have built our own
platform i'm here i'm here on one of the
platforms that we have built but that's
not enough
okay we also need to rein in the
government and we also need to rein in
the much more powerful platforms that
are working in collaboration with the
government
what gensake
is showing you in that clip
is that
the free marketplace of ideas ain't so
freaking free is it
spotify is
i guess kind of acting of its own accord
in
in response to the workings of the
market i guess that's kind of true
they've got a bunch of libs who are
protesting them and so they're they're
reacting to that they're also reacting
to the president of the united states
who is using the full force of that
office
to pressure a private company to censor
a political dissident not even that much
of a political dissonance just a guy
named joe rogan who is a liberal who is
a left winger who kind of sort of
descends from the dominant ruling class
sometimes and the president of the
united states is using his power to get
the private company to shut joe rogan up
that that problem is not merely going to
be fixed by win hearts and minds in the
culture you need to wield the government
to punish
the
other political actors who are doing
this and to bring into line the
so-called private companies that are
very often working in collaboration with
the government
it was very fashionable in the sort of
conservatism
talking points of the
1990s and 2000s to draw a clean
distinction
between private enterprise and the
government big government bad private
enterprise good even if it's big
corporations even if those corporations
are basically just products of the
government
google is google a private corporation
uh sort of kind of
i mean it was founded with a lot of
government money actually and developed
with a lot of government money and it
reacts very closely with the government
they work together on a lot of things
but so it's sort of private it's sort of
public it's sort of the culture it's
sort of politics
we need to wield all the power we can
the left is wielding all the power they
can joe biden is
through his spokesman
trying to censor joe rogan
a
ufc loving dmt taking pot smoking
podcaster
okay
we need to fight back too or we're gonna
get completely rolled over
liberals have been complaining over the
past few days about how
too many people are watching joe rogan
not enough people are watching cnn of
course every single sensible person in
america trusts joe rogan more than they
trust cnn and now there's there's even
more reason for that there is trouble at
bruin at cnn the president of cnn jeff
zucker
has been fired
why was he fired well there's two
stories there's the story you're reading
about in the press and then there's the
real story
jeff sucker the the ostensible reason
why the president of cnn was fired is
because he was stooping his deputy
allison gollust
and that this was an and a consensual
office relationship
jeff zucker is no longer married neither
is alison gallus though previously they
were married and so it was consensual
and it was an office relationship but
they didn't disclose it and because jeff
sucker didn't fill out a form with hr
that's why he got fired
if you believe that
i have got a bridge in brooklyn to sell
you obviously there's a lot more to it
there's a lot more to it because cnn
already knew about that relationship
there's a lot more to it because
apparently a lot of people in media knew
about that relationship katie couric
wrote about it in her book
in in katie couric's memoir she wrote
about how jeff zucker she heavily
insinuated that jeff zucker and this
woman she named the woman
were obviously shtipping one another
the affair appears to have broken up
both marriages
and then
zucker is now being ousted because of it
it gets even dirtier than that alison
gollust the paramour here the executive
at cnn was the former communications
director for andrew cuomo andrew cuomo
whose brother chris cuomo was one of the
anchors at cnn andrew cuomo
who was built up
into the fantasy of the greatest
governor in america almost exclusively
by cnn
so dirty so corrupt
and then the cherry on top of the
corruption sunday is everyone at cnn
apparently knew about this a lot of
other people in the media knew about
this
and nobody reported on it
other than katie couric mentioning it in
her book
this story
perfectly perfectly encapsulates
the corruption of the establishment
media
in cap it really illustrates two things
one the corruption of the establishment
media you can't trust these people
because they obviously
they are literally sleeping with one
another right they are literally in bed
with one another the politicians and the
media executives and the whole morass
the whole
liberal establishment and they're not
going to cover things do you
do you think
it is just a coincidence that the
network that employs cuomo's brother and
cuomo's former communications director
where that communications director was
sleeping with the president of the
network that they they would just happen
to give
unduly positive coverage to the governor
of new york andrew cuomo do you think
that's just a coincidence no it's a very
corrupt arrangement and this isn't the
only one
there are lots of these the
establishment media is teeming with them
that's the first thing this teaches you
the second thing this teaches you
and it seems obvious but it bears
repeating
you need to flee from sin
i don't want to sound like a preacher
man but you need to flee from sin
especially sexual sin because that's the
easiest to give into it's so basic to
our nature
and it'll get you it'll get you this guy
jeff zucker you know they didn't fire
him because of the affair that everyone
knew about they fired him because they
wanted him out they used the affair as a
pretext
but he opened himself up to that
he he compromised himself when he
engaged in that affair
that's what we do when we engage in this
is why by the way
the
libs the rulers want us
to
just do a lot of drugs and look at a lot
of porn and engage in lots of weird sex
stuff and do and do all sort they want
to compromise us okay
so that we're always sitting it's it's
just like getting getting compromi on
somebody okay
governments politicians have known about
this for many many years that's what
happened to jeff zucker here
he is not the only one he is not the
only one
with this kind of dirt on him
there's a real downside for for jeff
zucker
and when when you find yourself facing a
downside it's probably a good idea to
get upside people who are driving a lot
are saving two to three hundred dollars
per month they're getting that in cash
back simply by using get upside how do
you do it you go to the get upside app
whether you're in the app store whether
you're in the google play store you just
download that app for free
and then you get 25 cents per gallon
cash back every single time you fill up
your car with one exception i do i want
to be perfectly upfront one exception if
you use promo code knowles
you'll actually get 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first fill up
it's a great way is gas is going through
the roof this is a really great way to
save at the pump the cash back is super
easy every single time you fill up you
get that 25 cents cash back
you you get that straight to your bank
account or through paypal or to amazon
gift cards or a number of other stores
as well very very simple
just download the free get upside app
today use promo code knowles to get 25
cents per gallon or more cash back on
your first tank that is code knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
cnn for their part
as their president is ousted ostensibly
over a sex scandal
they go on air
brian stelter and some other dude and
that chick whose name i forget she's the
blonde lady they go on cnn
and they basically defend jeff zucker
i do just want to say something personal
for a moment if i may so that is i mean
i i feel it deeply personally but also i
think i speak for all of us and our
colleagues this is an incredible loss
it's an incredible loss jeff is a
remarkable person and an incredible
leader
he has this uncanny ability to make i
think
every one of us feel special and
valuable in our own way even though he
is managing an international news
organization of thousands of people i
just know that he had this unique
ability to make us feel special and i
don't think that that comes around all
the time and i think again it's an
incredible loss and i just think it's so
regrettable
how
it happened if what you're reporting is
true these are two consenting
adults who are both executives that they
can't have a private relationship um
feels wrong it just feels wrong doesn't
it
wow what a rosy picture cnn lady is
painting of what happened they're two
executives uh sure the only reason this
woman was an executive at least
according to katie kirk's book is
because jeff zucker was stopping her
that's how she got her job that's how
she got promoted
do you think that is fair to the other
women at the network who maybe got
passed over for a promotion because they
weren't
sleeping on top of jeff sucker do you do
you think that's fair to them
do you think we ought to promote a
culture
empowering women in the workplace if you
want to get ahead there's one easy way
to do it ladies
just go knocking on that door at your
boss's office and close the door behind
you that's right that's how you can get
ahead it's two consenting adults isn't
that fine
two consenting adults who were married
who broke up their marriages because of
this
and created a
highly unprofessional workplace dynamic
that's fine it's just two consenting
adults
yeah people can consent to things that
are bad that shouldn't be allowed
people do it all the time we shouldn't
tolerate that
it's bad for them it's bad for their
marriages it's bad for society it's bad
for the company
but this this is what
is encouraged
and this is why you can't trust
the establishment media
you can't trust it
there is no way
even if just one aspect
of this one story were true
you could never you could never trust
cnn's reporting of andrew cuomo
the fact that his brother until recently
fredo was one of the
top anchors at their network
how are you going to trust their
coverage of andrew cuomo
one of the most powerful guys there is
the brother of cuomo the fact that one
of their apparently top executives
was the former communications director
for cuomo how are you going to trust
she this woman was being talked about as
a replacement for jeff soccer
just a year or two ago
yes alison gollus she might replace jeff
zucker whenever he retires she was very
high up how are you going to trust their
coverage of cuomo
how did this
news come out well the news was already
leaked but why why would jeff zucker
step down now because apparently chris
cuomo this is just being reported chris
cuomo
had audio
compromising audio compromise on jeff
zucker on this issue
so they they're all blackmailing each
other they all know each other's dirt
and they're all covering up for each
other and who gets screwed you the
viewer you the public
you the people who are having
information concealed from you
or who are just being outright deceived
through active lies
this is just one little episode
but it's one episode that you see
countless times a day
on countless issues throughout the
establishment media
i
sort of feel bad
for everyone in this situation because
everyone
did bad things and then everyone tried
to catch other people doing bad things
to cover up their bad things and it was
just game theory and they were all just
they're they're just sort of
waiting to see who would crack first it
was a prisoner's dilemma
and finally it did
one great way to avoid this
don't do it i i remember before i got
married i asked andrew clavin that old
sage i asked him for advice i said how
do you have a good long marriage
he says uh it's pretty simple don't
sleep with other people
and then don't get divorced there you go
that's how you have a good long marriage
don't stop other people don't get
divorced okay easier said than done i
know
drew has also made the point that every
man has two drinks and a wink away from
ruining his life so it's possible we're
all tempted but this would be a good
reason why not to because it can come
back and it really compromises you and
it compromises your integrity and it can
lead to great humiliation
speaking of liberals getting in trouble
at legacy media outlets i've been
meaning to talk about this
for two days now and we just we've run
out of time each day but i have to get
to
whoopi goldberg whoopi goldberg made a
very
impolitic comment about the holocaust
she has now been suspended there are
calls for her to be fired she's furious
that she was suspended at all
here's the comment in case you haven't
heard it
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy
but it's not it's not about ideas
but these are two white groups of people
well how do we have to blame you to see
them as white
race peop goes down this alley let's
talk about it for what it is it's how
people treat each other it's a problem
it doesn't matter if you're black or
white because black white jews uh it's
ha everybody eats each other so is it
if you're uncomfortable if you hear
about mouse
should you be worried should your child
say oh my god i i wonder if that's me no
that's not what they're going to say
they're going to say i don't want to be
like that i
i want you to pull over if you're
driving i want if you are watching this
or listening to this and i want you to
sit down because i have
i think the most contrarian take on this
whole episode of anyone that i have
heard on either side of the aisle
while whoopi goldberg is obviously 100
wrong as an historical matter
i think she kind of makes a good point
all right i just i said it i said it i
know people are going to be shocked and
offended and rent their garments and
clutch their pearls
she is 100
wrong as a matter of history hitler very
much perpetrated the holocaust because
he hated the jews he viewed the jews as
a race not just as a religious group but
as a race the jews historically are a
race and a religion it's very difficult
for modern people to understand that a
tribe of people
and a religion of people could be the
same thing because in modernity we don't
really think of tribes anymore we don't
really think of nations anymore we think
that any people can be part of any
religion and the two are completely
separated that was not true in the
ancient world that is not true
historically of judaism actually that
idea is really a product of christianity
when christianity comes and saint paul
says that there is neither jew nor greek
nor slave nor free but all are one in
christ jesus that is a pretty radical
and novel idea and so because
christianity shaped the development of
the west it is it's the most important
feature that shaped the development of
the west then that's how we think of
things but that wasn't always true and
that is not the case with judaism so yes
whoopi is wrong
that the holocaust was not about race
and the holocaust specifically refers to
hitler's
genocide of the jews hitler also killed
millions of ukrainians hitler also
killed millions of russians hitler also
killed lots and lots of catholics hitler
also killed what half a million gypsies
something like that hitler hitler also
killed lots and lots of other people
that's not really what we're referring
to with the holocaust they are separate
things hitler killed a lot of people
and he he killed the jews because
they're a race however the point that
whoopi makes that i really like that i
think actually is a pretty conservative
point
is that
when we're talking about something even
this you know is extremely evil i guess
the most extremely evil thing you can
think of in modernity the holocaust
the essence of that evil is not race we
are really tempted these days especially
by the left to say that every bad thing
is racism that racism is the most evil
thing in the world there is nothing more
evil than racism it is the core evil
this is why the original sin of america
is racism that's the language they use
but it's not the original sin of america
all of the original sin of the whole
world is original sin and it's deeper
the issue here is that the imagination
of man's heart is evil from the very
beginning you can't boil down the evil
in the world just to race
it's it's deeper than that it's actually
more fundamental than that
and and so whoopi i don't i bet you
whoopi goldberg would have no idea what
i'm talking about if i explained to her
the implications of the things that you
were saying and if i corrected her on
the historical record but that point is
very important because if we try to boil
down all evil to race
we're going to come up short
it's much much deeper than that and it's
and ultimately it is religious and that
and and because all human conflict is
theological you've got to get down to
that issue too and the more that we just
babble and prattle about race the worse
off we're going to be
you know big things are happening here
at the daily wire our first original
production shut-in will premiere
one week from today directed by dj
caruso executive produced by daily wire
co-founders
the film is centered around a young
single mother who's barricaded inside a
pantry by her violent ex-boyfriend while
using nothing but her voice to guide her
two small children to escape escalating
danger
it's a tale of redemption while
remaining an intense suspenseful
thriller that delivers riveting action
without missing a beat check out the
trailer
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
the film premiere is a week from today
thursday february 10th and will be free
for all to stream on youtube and
dailywire.com after that it will be
available only to daily wire subscribers
so now would be the perfect time to sign
up also if you haven't heard of jonathan
isaac yet
where are you where have you been living
the nba star stood strong with his
values while everyone else kneeled and
faced heavy criticism from the media for
his views on social issues and vaccines
over the past few years which is why i'm
extremely excited to announce that he is
writing a book with us it's called why i
stand jonathan's book will be about the
rise of his basketball career his
journey into faith his strength to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
check out the teaser
the orlando magic's 23 year old starting
forward is deeply religious and proudly
unvaccinated on friday isaac got
attention for choosing not to kneel in
unison with his teammates or to wear a
black lives matter shirt my name is
jonathan isaac i play for the orlando
magic
and i'm writing a book with the daily
wire
[Music]
coverage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes in
[Music]
book will be one of the first under
daily wire's new publishing arm dw books
we could not be happier to have him on
board the book is available for
pre-order now at amazon so reserve your
copy today we'll be right back with a
lot more
speaking of the nazis
there is a riveting story in rolling
stone
i'm serious and that's not even a joke
i'm not being facetious rolling stone a
very left-wing outlet has a really
interesting
long essay
about an undercover federal agent
says here's the headline he spent 25
years infiltrating nazis the clan and
biker gangs
it's about this this fed
who would go into all these radical
far-right groups radical far-right
domestic terrorist groups all around
america the ones who we're told pose the
greatest terror threat
we've got to be on guard there's a
klansman around every corner and he
would infiltrate them and he would
thwart their
actions
i think the point of this essay
is that
as i've just said there are nazis and
klansmen everywhere and we've got to be
on the lookout and and we've got to
suppress the right wing in america
ironically though the effect of the
essay i think is to prove all of us
right-wingers correct when we say
that these the nazis that we're told
about the klansmen that we're told about
are very often just feds it's very often
just feds larping live-action
role-playing this nazi stuff
and and inventing a threat where none
really exists or where the threat is
relatively
minor
this is just from the essay by his count
there are 600 fbi agents who are
certified undercover employees but some
of them do the work of backstopping
agents creating false credentials and
social media profiles for uce working in
the field
so there's 600 of these guys running
around or doing their work online 600
around the country
at one point in this account the
undercover fed
talks about how when he was infiltrating
one of these these nazi klansmen
whatever groups
he ran into another undercover fed and
he only knew about the other undercover
fed because he had heard about him
somewhere like you know there are 600 of
them so there are a lot of these
undercover feds but but he had heard
about him they had some connection they
said oh hey look it's like that it's
like that spider-man meme you know oh
hey it's you oh hey it's you
this is actually how i imagine most clan
meetings to go whatever clan meetings
still exist in america whatever nazi
meetings there are i
suspect that when when they show up
it's kind of like that fed picnic
remember the rally for the justice for
january 6th that happened a few months
ago and the only people who showed up
were journalists
liberals and undercover federal agents
and like one klansmen from appalachia
who didn't get the memo
but all
probably
99 of the people at this thing and it
was so obvious there were photos going
around of all these dudes wearing the
same logo-less shorts and t-shirts
they're all wearing their garmin watch
they've all got fed sunglasses on they
all got a nice fresh haircut probably in
the basement of langley
they're all they're all checking their
sixes
a lot of situational awareness these
guys
blended in like uh like a clown
you know like a big colorful clown it
was so obvious
and i and i think that's the point here
what we have
been saying for years that this threat
that we're told oh it's the racists the
nazis the white supremacists it's i
think it's mostly imagined and contrived
and actually being encouraged
by our federal government and the whole
point of this piece by the way
is to advocate for an even greater
surveillance state the whole point of
the piece is to say this is a real
problem we need even more of these guys
we got to stamp out the right wing
if you read it carefully
really makes really makes the opposite
point
maybe these federal agents who are
protecting us from phantoms maybe maybe
they're doing more harm than good maybe
they're the ones creating the illusion
of this threat
speaking of agents of the state
there's a parent right now
number of parents in the north penn
school district right outside of philly
who showed up to a school board meeting
to report on something that if this
mother had not had courage we probably
never would have heard of this came from
libs of tick tock
that a fifth grade teacher
lined up students by their race these
are ten-year-olds and made the white
kids apologize to the black kids i
actually pulled my daughter out of am
cult
because of the fifth grade teacher who
lined those students up from whitis to
darkest made them turn around and the
white ones needed to apologize to the
black ones now do not tell me that it
did not happen
okay in this district you need to put an
end to this
kids do not see color and you are
segregating them and you are separating
them
this is not okay
do something or get out of those damn
chairs
i love it i love her righteous anger and
i love the point that she's making this
is not okay the teachers who do this
need to be canceled they need to be
fired they need to not work as teachers
again i love cancel culture canceled
culture's awesome when it's for the
right reasons all cultures cancel every
single person supports cancer culture
plenty of people who pretend to hate
cancer culture right now are calling to
they're going to cancel whoopi goldberg
maybe they have good reason to
i think there are plenty of good reasons
to ostracize people there are standards
there are taboos
there are consequences for what people
say of course
certainly that should be enforced
against this teacher
without question now it actually ties in
with the whoopee point a little bit too
because let's take away all of whoopi's
stupid historical commentary on the
holocaust
and let's just get to the
ostensibly deeper philosophical point
she's trying to make which is that
evil doesn't just boil down to race it
boils down to man's inhumanity toward
man it really boils down to the
perversion and fallenness of man's heart
if it is the case
that it's really all about race all evil
in the world is about race and white
supremacy then the exercise that this
teacher is doing in her classroom is
totally justified
if it's really if the all the problems
of the world stem from white supremacy
then yeah the white kids probably should
apologize to the black kids
shouldn't they and they should be taught
that whiteness is bad and blackness is
good
and white people should always feel
ashamed of their skin color
and you've got a root out out damn spot
out damn whiteness right if if the
racial ideology of the left is true
if it's not
if racism is merely a symptom of a
deeper fallenness of the world
that is not merely about one group or
some other group but is actually about
the man in the mirror and our own
cracked broken
hearts that are corrupt from the
beginning
well then this exercise doesn't make any
sense at all
and
the answer to this by the way is not the
what the libs are doing right now is
they're saying one group good the other
group evil
what a lot of people want all the kids
to be told is you're all good you're all
good people deep down what the kids
should really be taught is no you're all
fallen you're not totally evil
you're not 100 irredeemable
but you're not good either you're fallen
and you need humility and you are a
sinner that's the nature of this world
and we need to practice virtue and we
need to be on guard against sin and we
need a redeemer
that is what i know it sounds so radical
now to say that that's what education
was until like five minutes ago
by which i mean 60 70 years ago when the
secularists really took over the
educational institution and what
happened since that time our education
has crumbled and little 10 year olds are
being told to feel ashamed of themselves
for the color of their skin
this is a lot deeper than just some
stupid racial theory this this requires
an entire overhaul of how we see
ourselves and our country
starting to think these teachers are the
baddies
you know these teachers who are they're
such good people but they seem to
they actually on on closer inspection
seem to be the baddies there there's an
abortionist who who
was tweeting out the other day
her defense of abortion
she tweeted out she said being against
abortion
if you are against abortion you do not
have the moral high ground
yes you do
you do because it's because it's immoral
to support abortion and it's moral to
oppose abortion and so just on that
issue alone you do have the moral high
ground if you oppose abortion because
abortion is evil
so then she
responds to her own tweet and she says
being against abortion is being for
reproductive coercion
so i'll repeat if you're against
abortion you do not have the moral high
ground
the lady doth protest too much me thinks
when people are really confident of
something that they believe in they
don't have to constantly repeat it in an
angrier and angrier way
if if you're if you're confident if
you're secure if you have a
good formation of what you believe then
you just say it and it's clear and you
don't need to yell and scream and cry
about it you just say it
i looked at this woman's bio
and her self bio in her bio she writes
do gooder
do-gooder in her own bio
the thing about do-gooders is the real
do-gooders
don't say that they're do-gooders
they don't they don't have to they just
do good things
the people who say i'm a do-gooder i'm a
good person i'm so virtuous i'm so
wonderful
they're saying it one because i think
they're trying to convince themselves
and two because
it's not
manifestly true from their behavior
but but
saying so will not make it so the left
believes that language
because there's no such thing as
objective reality if we just say certain
we just say that a man is a woman then
the man really will be a woman
they'll just say if we just say that
vicious people are virtuous people then
they really will be virtuous people and
vice versa but that's not the case
that's not the case reality has a say
too i saw
one of the more disturbing stories not
because anyone died or it was
particularly gruesome it was a
disturbing story about where our culture
is headed it was a local news story
about the metaverse about how we're all
going to plug into virtual reality and
mark zuckerberg is going to control the
world and we're going to leave the world
built by god and we're going to go into
a world built by mark zuckerberg isn't
that going to be so much better and in
the news story they said the future
not just of commerce not just of
schooling
but of the future of church
is going to be in the metaverse
metaverse is an online platform where
people can use virtual reality headsets
to transport themselves to any realm
they wish including church jackie bagnes
explains the appeal of digital
worshipping in the metaverse
i believe the future of the church is
the metaverse a growing number of people
are turning to the metaverse for their
religious services as folks pop on
virtual reality headsets and partake in
digital church let me have someone read
verses 19 through 21 but just because
it's virtual doesn't mean it's less
interactive than going to a physical
house of worship if anything vr church
participants say it enhances their
religious experience i was able to see
a rendering
of the verse i was reading which made
scripture much more meaningful uh for me
and it's so much more than scripture
readings baptisms are also taking place
in the metaverse the rebirth that you
got through jesus christ do you want
this yes i do yes i baptize you but this
kind of worshiping isn't just for the
tech savvy
baptisms are not taking place in the
metaverse that's the problem
maybe people think that when they log
into their video game and have their
little character put their head under
the little digital water that they're
they're being baptized they're not
they're not
they're not going to church
even in the video game
they are they're playing a video game
our faith christianity
is an incarnational faith it's so
incarnational that the second person of
the trinity the divine logic of the
universe took on flesh
he was was incarnate
of the virgin mary
incarnate
conceived by the holy spirit incarnate
of the virgin mary and became man
and became man at that point when you're
reciting the creed in christianity you
actually get down on your knees
because it's
this is the central fact that god became
man took on flesh and what these
heretics are trying to do
are is take the flesh away
and this has huge even if you're not
christian even if you're not
particularly religious this has huge
implications for your politics charlie
kirk the other day got in trouble with
media matters because he made a point
that i've made on this show dozens of
times that transgenderism is such a big
focus of the left not only because
they're creepy
perverted sexual theorists on the left
who want to upend all traditional sexual
mores but
because they want to
get rid of the flesh
they want it to be a stepping stone into
transhumanism
they want to say that your your body
doesn't matter your location doesn't
matter your family doesn't matter your
nation doesn't matter real reality
doesn't matter we can just be
transported wherever we want in the
metaverse go into your pod work on your
laptop and isolate yourself
that's what this is about a denial of
the importance of the flesh
but you can't have that real community
real
worship real life happens with your body
not on a couch not with some goggles on
not living in some dystopian hell
created by mark zuckerberg
take the goggles off
go into real life the sunshine is
beautiful and the church is much more
beautiful
too
now speaking of the real world
speaking i see why the democrats want to
deny the real world
because they are basing their political
views largely on fantasies fantasies
like the idea that a baby's not a baby
that a man can become a woman
fantasies of how the economy is going to
work fantasies about how geopolitically
so they they like fantasy much more than
they like reality that's why they're
denying reality in reality though
joe biden is a very unpopular president
in
fantasy joe biden's the most popular
president ever who got 700 bazillion
votes in 2020.
in reality joe biden
according to the majority of voters
is the worst president ever
rasmussen and the national pulse
conducted a survey
on people's opinion of joe biden
question was who's the worst president
in history
54
of likely voters believe that joe biden
will remem be remembered as one of the
worst presidents in american history
only
25 percent think his presidency will be
remembered as
about average
when the same question was asked about
donald trump
it was a much smaller number who thought
he would be one of the worst presidents
in history 43
said that when it was asked about obama
it was even lower 33
said that
what's weird is it's not just the
republicans skewing this even among
democrats
more democrats ranked biden
as one of the worst presidents as ranked
him as one of the best presidents 28
said he'll be one of the worst 27
percent says
say that he will be one of the best
this is bad news for biden
in part
you've got this issue of when presidents
are in the hot seat
they're less popular than they are
remembered
so this is why obama
only 33 say that about him this is why
bill clinton's image has been
rehabilitated it's why george w bush is
even to some degree has been
rehabilitated
but that doesn't explain everything away
for biden presidents are supposed to be
popular at the beginning of their
administration
then there they get less popular over
time by the time they leave office
usually they're relatively unpopular
then it bounces back again
joe biden's been in office for one year
and he's already one of the least
popular presidents in american history
why is that
i think it's very simple i think it's
because you can't deny reality forever i
think that joe biden
began his campaign on lies the very
first claim of joe biden's presidential
campaign is that donald trump called
nazis
very fine people at charlottesville that
didn't happen it was completely made up
and the lie was that
donald trump's a white supremacist then
the lie was that he was going to
completely shut down the virus then the
lie was that the economy was going to be
great then the lie was that there was
going to be peace and harmony around the
world then then the lie was foreign
affairs were going to get better then
and then none of that happened
everything got
worse
this is one of the great conservative
consolations is that you can't deny
reality forever you can put your little
goggles on you can shut out the world
you can try to just live in your fantasy
you can't do it forever eventually
reality is going to come back on you
so how are the libs explaining all of
this away
why biden is so deeply unpopular why
things are really not going well why
everyone seems seems to really dislike
this guy
according to brian stelter according to
cnn it's it's the obvious answer
it's the answer it's the cause of all
the evil in the world
it's racism
high conflict is a force that causes
people to lie awake at night and fear
for the future
and i can see this kind of conflict
right now with a looming supreme court
confirmation battle
i guess i could call it a confirmation
process maybe i should but i default to
the word battle because that's the way
it's portrayed in the press and look
maybe it won't really be a battle some
conservative activists are saying
they're not planning to go scorched
earth against president biden's nominee
to replace justice stephen breyer since
whoever the nominee is will not change
the balance of the court
but let's be honest
fox wants a fight
right-wing radio and tv wants a fight
they need a fight over the supreme court
they are already starting a fight
that's rooted in white identity politics
all the fox's primetime shows are
outraged that biden has committed to
nominating a justice who is black and
female
there it is it's rooted what's it rooted
in what's the root of all of this evil
all this tension all this conflict the
root
white racism this is why guys this is
why i'm
sort of
willing to give whoopi goldberg at least
a little bit of grace here
because yes she was totally wrong about
the history but at least some person
in the establishment
is is admitting that not the root of all
evil in the world is not race that
there's actually something deeper than
race
you can be you can be wrong about the
historical point but but correct about
the deeper rot
that undergirds
human conflict
stelter won't do that
the reason we are told the reason that
conservatives are going to oppose joe
biden's inevitably radical leftist
court nominee who's going to want to
enshrine
mass baby slaughter in law in imaginary
inc in the constitution the only reason
we oppose that
is because of racism or whatever
even when joe biden is admitting that
his nominee is going to take this
radical view of the constitution he
admitted it yesterday
there's always a renewed national debate
every time we
nominate any president nominates a
justice
because the constitution has always
evolved me slightly uh in terms of
additional rights or cursing rights etc
and it's always an issue
the constitution's always evolving
slightly oh because the constitution's a
living breathing document right it's not
it's not it's a piece of paper it's very
much dead it's got words on it the words
have meaning we can read those words our
lowercase constitution the way that we
all kind of live together that is
evolving that's always changing but the
cat the whole point of the capital c
constitution on paper is that it doesn't
change it's just text and if you want to
change it you can you need to go through
the amendment process
and so there's a built-in way to change
the constitution but it is not steadily
always necessarily evolving
so what biden's saying is i'm going to
nominate someone who's going to
completely ignore the constitution and
read into it whatever whims and caprices
she has
and what does brian stelter say it's
just white identity politics
there it's not white identity politics
if it were that would only be a response
to leftist identity politics
whether it be
them the left ginning up black identity
politics hispanic identity politics any
other kind of identity politics
that that comes first there was a report
from pew research that showed that white
people in america have the lowest racial
consciousness of any group by a lot it's
about 15 for white people it's over 50
for every other group so please don't
prattle on to me about the scrooge of
white identity politics it barely exists
and these battles by the way only happen
from the democrat side it started with
robert bork then it went to clarence
thomas against a black man by the way
democrats joe biden and then it went to
brett kavanaugh
those are that's the only place where
this high conflict is it's total
projection from the left
and it's not it's not
primarily or ultimately about race
it's about the way we view ourselves as
a country it's about the way we view the
constitution it's about the country that
we want to live in it's about the way
that we view
ourselves
the democrats
have done a very very good job
of reordering the way that all of us
view ourselves and and the way that all
of us fear our countrymen
but reality does creep in in the end
reality the reality is dawning on people
is that enough to lead to
a political upheaval one can hope i'm
michael knowles is the michael knowles
she'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show jeff
zucker resigns from cnn over revelations
he was stopping his closest colleague
who happens to be a former comms
director for andrew cuomo we'll get into
that today give it a listen